TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan
for "The Developer
Show", and this
is your update about the coolest
developer news from Google
in the last week.
AIY Projects has
launched new versions
of their do-it-yourself
artificial intelligence kits.
The voice kit lets you build
a voice controlled speaker
while the vision
kit lets you build
a camera that learns to
recognize people and objects.
Photos and links
are on the post.
Android Things Developer
Preview 8 is now available.
It is the final preview release
and represents the final API
service exposed in the
Android Things support library
for the upcoming
stable release, which
means there will
be no more breaking
API changes before the
1.0 release of the SDK.
For more details, release notes,
and the updated SDK reference,
take a look at the post.
Google Play Protect is bringing
Safe Browsing to web view
by default, starting
in April 2018
with the release of WebView 66.
Google Safe Browsing
protects users
across the web from phishing
and malware attacks.
Links to learn about
customizing, controlling,
and testing Safe
Browsing are on the post.
Some of the new
functionality we've
delivered for Firebase
Authentication
includes password list
sign-in with email link,
custom claims on clients, and
server side session management
controls.
For more details on making
registering and signing
in users even easier,
take a look at the post.
DeepVariant version
0.6 is now available.
It's a deep learning
model that's
been trained to analyze
genetic sequences
and accurately identify
the differences-- known
as variants-- that
make us all unique.
This release includes some
major accuracy improvements
that are outlined in
detail on the post.
PostgreSQL is now
generally available
and fully supported for
all customers on our cloud
SQL fully managed
database service.
This means it's
backed by Google's 24
by 7 SRE team, high availability
with automatic failover,
and our SLA.
Links to get started
are on the post.
Also now generally available is
Dialogflow Enterprise Edition,
which you can use to
build voice and text based
conversational
experiences powered
by machine learning and
natural language understanding.
Example screenshots and links
to get started are on the post.
HashiCorp Vault is
an open source tool
for secrets management.
We just announced
some improvements
to the Google Cloud storage
back end for HashiCorp Vault,
including high availability,
support for default application
credentials, and
enterprise-grade security.
Details are on the post.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
"The Developer Show."
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[LAUGHING]
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, that's good.